retour au 19/20 et aux titres de
l'actualité en urss le front 70 de la
guerre entre azéri et arménien mikhaïl
gorbatchev est en position très
difficile c'est françois mitterrand qui
l'estiment et qui souhaite qu'on lui
vienne en aide à l'est est toujours
l'albanie nous a ouvert ses portes en
exclusivité pour la première fois des
journalistes étrangers ont pu faire le
point réel de la situation au pays des
aigles
reportage dans quelques minutes en
france la grève des urgences n'a pas
perturbé gravement l'accueil des malades
dans les hôpitaux mais le conflit reste
brûlant enfin véronique le guen a mis
fin à ses jours elle avec 33 ans et
avait fait la une de l'actualité fin 88
en restant près de quatre mois isolé au
fond d'un gouffre entre arméniens et
azéris la tragédie actuelle peut se
transformer demain en catastrophe
nationale
c'est le kremlin qui ce matin a lancé
dans la pravda ce véritable cri de
détresse et ce soir en azerbaïdjan la
situation est toujours très tendue
le front s'est recentrée autour de bakou
où l'armée soviétique temps toujours
d'entrer seule éclaircie l'évacuation
des réfugiés arméniens vers moscou
le point avec francine raymond extremis
aventuriers responsable c'est ainsi que
mikhaïl gorbatchev qualifie tout ce qui
est anase rba dion appelle à la
constitution d'une république islamique
au delà du conflit entre les arméniens
et les azéri aujourd'hui l'azerbaïdjan
est entré en rébellion ouverte avec
moscou le kremlin lance un ultimatum aux
nationalistes de bakou et menaces
d'employer la force si la population
continue de se poser à l'entrée de
l'armée rouge dans la capitale face à
une situation qui pourrait déboucher sur
une catastrophe nationale le pouvoir
central n'a plus le choix
mes limites de la glace nost aucune
image nous parvient de bakou les caméras
s'arrête à la frontière entre l'arménie
et l'azerbaïdjan
on sait tout de même que depuis hier
soir plusieurs milliers de manifestants
bloquent le siège du parti communiste de
bakou
selon la presse soviétique des azéris
soviétique serait passé en iran pour
assister à la prière du vendredi
information confirmée par téhéran ce
soir les troupes soviétiques font route
vers le centre de la capitale azérie
mais paradoxalement au moment où il
durcit le ton
mikhaïl gorbatchev revient sur sa
décision de rappeler
harvick pour les envoyer sur le front du
caucase la mesure a suscité un trop
grand mécontentement dans la population
soviétique
les très nombreux arméniens qui depuis
70 ans ont choisi de s'établir en france
suivent de très près bien sûr
l'évolution de cette véritable guerre
qui éprouvent leurs frères restés en
urss
la communauté arménienne de lyon est
particulièrement nombreuse et
particulièrement mobilisés très
justement pour tenter de venir en aide
aux arméniens de bakou et du haut
karabakh la communauté lyonnaise a même
envisagé de constituer des brigades de
volontaires et cela sans même sans même
être sûr de pouvoir repartir
reportage carole données choqué la
communauté arménienne à 30 kilomètres
d'erevan un village a été attaqué par
les azéris l'information est tombée hier
mais depuis une semaine la diaspora
rhônalpine se mobilisent contre les
massacres
lundi une manifestation mardi appelle à
la mobilisation par le parti socialiste
arménien sur les ondes de radio arménie
mercredi meeting
mais là on leur donne de faux espoirs
objet la constitution de corps de
volontaires pour partir aider sur place
le peuple arménien vic cana 25 ans y les
géomètres son unique désirent faire
partie de ceux qui iront là bas
notre but c'est toujours de défendre le
peuple arménien et puis reste souvent à
l'aide au secours de ces arméniens quoi
et vous êtes prêt quand même à risquer
votre vie mais bien sûr ils ont risqué
leur vie pour qu'enfin nous si on court
un danger qu'on peut courir n'importe
qui je préfère aider mais mes confrères
mais mes parents maignien comme ça je
serai que je sais que je suis proposé
mourir pour une cause et pourtant viken
comme tous ceux qui veulent aller là-bas
n'est pas un guerrier un simple amoureux
de son peuple de sa culture
s'il part c'est avant tout pour soutenir
soulager financièrement et moralement
les volontaires n'ont pas encore pris
les armes d'ailleurs il ne saurait pas
s'en servir
nous sommes les premiers ce soir sur fr3
pouvoir l'affirmer l'albanie n'a pas
encore bougé dans la foulée des
révolutions successives d'europe de
l'est
certains ont cru que la petite halle
vanille marxiste léniniste avaient ou
allaient à son tour basculer en fin de
semaine dernière les yougoslaves eux
mêmes affirmé qu'il y avait eu des
émeutes en albanie et que l'état
d'urgence qui avait été décrété et bien
à ce soir en exclusivité la 3 peut faire
le point sur la situation réelle en
albanie nos deux reporters jérôme
cathala et jean-michel des stocks sont
en effet les seuls journalistes
étrangers à avoir pu tourner ces
derniers jours en albanie ils se sont
tout de suite rendu à shkodra la ville
du nord du pays
la semaine dernière les yougoslaves
affirmé que la ville était en ébullition
et proche de la révolte il n'en est rien
en voici la preuve
faisons de 1990 la dernière année du 8e
plan quinquennal une année de travail
acharné afin de réaliser et de dépasser
les prévisions dans tous les domaines un
slogan classique une ville normale à 120
km au nord de tirana
jusqu'au drame soixante dix mille
habitants présente toutes les apparences
de la quiétude la plus totale c'est ici
pourtant que selon des quotidiens
américains yougoslave aurait eu lieu des
manifestations d'étudiants suivi d'une
terrible répression militaire et même
d'exécution nous nous sommes rendus à
l'institut supérieur pédagogique qui
regroupe les cinq facultés de la ville
la travail 1400 étudiants et près de 100
professeurs par rapport à la france des
conditions d'études et de vie
difficilement imaginable pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de ce pays
toutes les portes se sont ouvertes
devant une équipe de télévision
occidentales mais nous n'étions pas
seuls nos trois accompagnateurs et
traducteur officiel de la télévision
albanaise avait préparé notre visite
guidée alors s'est il oui ou non passé
quelque chose dans cette université
durant le mois de décembre je ne sais
s'est rien passé c'est derrière moi
rien à signaler du tout pareil se sent
d'ailleurs que c'est l'immense en toi il
est même temps changent nous vivons dans
un pays socialiste et nous sommes très
heureux
voilà la vérité tous ces propos sont
tenus par nos ennemis des renégats ce
sont des menteurs
parce qu'il ya eu des événements en
plein air on en croit dont les autres
états de l'est par exemple et on a
trouvé à tout propos et missiles
alors s'il ya quelque chose et le bien
qu'on le dise qu'on les trous mais s'il
n'y en a pas pourquoi peut-on prouver à
tous profond quelque chose en album bref
une seule et même réponse
accompagné de l'éternel thèse du complot
complot organisé par la yougoslavie ou
la grèce afin de mettre l'albanie en
difficulté et ce soir là
l'union de la jeunesse organisait une
soirée dansante l'occasion rêvée de nous
démontrer que l'on s'amuse et que l'on
vit normalement à shkodra comme dans
toute l'albanie
c'était hier à shkodra donc en albanie
la suite de l' enquête de nos envoyés
spéciaux à 22h30 dans soir 3 tout de
suite ce qu'il faut encore savoir de
l'actualité à l'étranger caroline sims
mitterrand à budapest faisant référence
au cocasse gorbatchev affronte une
période très difficile
il faut l'aider il a également plaidé
pour un statut des minorités sans
toucher aux frontières ce matin il a été
le premier chef d'état à rendre hommage
aux victimes du soulèvement de 56 en
s'inclinant sur la tombe du premier
ministre imre nagui en afrique du sud
300 militants anti apartheid manifestent
contre l'arrivée de l'équipe britannique
de cricket celle ci ne respecte pas le
boycott du pays mais la police charge
brutalement les chiens se ruent sur les
manifestants il ya plusieurs blessés
raid de l'aviation israélienne sur le
liban sud près de saïda cible une radio
de l'ol paie émettant vers les
territoires occupés et des positions du
hezbollah pro-iranien deux attaques dans
la journée avec des ventes de gros
calibre bilan 5 morts 17 wc de disparus
c'est ça du seuil nice tête de file du
mouvement nationaliste palestinien dans
les territoires occupés arrêté il est
condamné à quatre jours de détention
préventive par un tribunal de jérusalem
accusés d'avoir encouragé 5 alors qu'il
n'ya à commettre des attentats
anti-israéliens scandale aves le tonne
le maire madame barry et s'arrêter cette
nuit par le feu et biya alors qu'il
était en train d'acheter de la cocaïne
et de fumer du crack un piège tendu par
le fbi une grande claque à celui qui
défendait depuis des années la lutte
contre la drogue
retour en france fin 88 nous l'avions
tous admirent et véronique le guen avait
mené durant près de quatre mois dans un
gouffre de l'aviron une expérience
d'isolement total
ce matin nous avons tous frémit en
apprenant que cette même jeune femme
s'était suicidé hier soir à paris et
bien sûr la question que l'on se pose ce
soit être savoir si cette expérience
exceptionnelle mais aussi très
éprouvante est à l'origine de ce geste
désespéré tout de suite des éléments de
réponse avec jean marc pitte
je sais comment je rentre je ne sais pas
comment je sortirai mais je compte
sortir comme il faut cette inquiétude
véronique le guen ne l'a évoqué que
quelques instants avant de rompre avec
le temps en descendant dans le gouffre
du valat [ __ ] à 80 mètres de profondeur
elle restera 112 jours dans un isolement
total
sans communication avec l'extérieur sans
notion du temps sans musique
outre la solitude elle devait y
supporter lui me dit
le froid mais aussi 9 électrodes collées
sur la tête et une sonde rectal qui
permettait aux chercheurs rester à la
surface de contrôle et ses rythmes
biologiques une période qu'elle devait
vivre seul face aux défis qu'elle
s'était lancée mais aussi seul face à
elle-même et à la réalité de son tir
acte de la situation extrême
et comme toutes situations extrêmes ça
peut révéler une certaine fragilité et
face à cette fragilité faire apparaître
certains certaine manière de se protéger
ou certaine manière de défendre une
fragilité que michel siffre
l'organisateur de l'expérience n'a
jamais soupçonnée s'il avait porté son
choix sur véronique le guen c'était à
cause de sa solidité mentale apparente
selon lui son suicide plus d'un an après
n'était en rien lié à cette épreuve
et voilà vous savez il y avait près de
300 expériences hors du temps et il n'y
a jamais eu de problème des sceptiques
donc je pense que c'est vraiment de
problème prouver qu'ils sont à la base
de sa non qui aura pas de séquelles
un optimisme que même son regard alors
ne semblait pas contredire pour soutenir
leurs revendications internes et chefs
de clinique ont déclenché ce matin dans
les hôpitaux et notamment à paris une
grève inédite celle des urgences et des
gardes le service minimum a tout de même
fonctionner sans grave problème
semble-t-il à l'heure qu'il est ce soir
les négociations sont au point mort et
tout le secteur de la santé menace en
fait d'engager une semaine d'action très
important et cela dès lundi avec une
manifestation très importante samedi
prochain ce qu'il faut encore savoir de
l'actualité aujourd'hui en france le
tour de france de l'actualité ce feeling
l enquête avance dans la sphère peschard
aujourd'hui la police a diffusé ces deux
portraits robots réalisés d'après les
témoignages des amis de la victime
présent le soir du meurtre
le docteur pêcheur a été enterré
aujourd'hui une cérémonie a rassemblé le
conseil municipal de marseille au
complet une cérémonie au cours de
laquelle robert vidéo a rendu un dernier
hommage à son ami interpellation hier à
saint jean de luz et à ciboure
il s'agit de cinq banques espagnoles
toujours en garde à vue aujourd'hui des
perquisitions à leur domicile ont permis
de découvrir des faux papiers français
et espagnols ainsi que des réveils
trafiqués pouvant servir de minuterie
une sixième personne est actuellement en
fuite
douloureux conflit à louviers il oppose
la dass à une assistante maternelle
colette bouquet refusé de restituer l'un
des enfants confiés à sa garde et le
cachet depuis jeudi
conséquence hier après-midi la dass est
venu reprendre sans avertir personne les
trois autres enfants que gardel
assistantes maternelles madame bouquet a
déjà élevé 39 ans la dass
vol insolite à blainville sur lot un pur
sang a été enlevé dans son box en plein
milieu de la nuit un enlèvement contre
rançon
le ravisseur a immédiatement réclamé 400
mille francs mais l'histoire se termine
bien grâce aux traces de sabots
le cheval a été retrouvé le voleur
arrêté on ignore toujours les vrais
mobiles durable on vient de l'apprendre
laurent fabius ne sera pas demain aux
obsèques que charles hernu à
villeurbanne seuls les vrais amis de
charles hernu ont leur place demain à
ses obsèques c'est madame hernu qui ce
soir justifier ainsi son refus de voir
monsieur fabius demain aux obsèques de
son mari je fabule c'est est rappelons
le premier ministre à l'époque de la
sphère du rainbow warrior
ils avaient situé les responsabilités au
niveau de charlie indus voilà pour
l'essentiel de l'actualité à 19h50
ensuite les programmes de faire trois ce
soir à 20h30 thalassa qui nous accueille
sur sa péniche à 21h35 le retour
d'arsène lupin et puis bien sûr les
infos à 22h30 soir 3 présenté par maguy
gilbert voilà nous allons vous quitter
je suis 7e péniche thalassa a marre et
donc sur la scène ici à paris merci
bonsoir tout de suite la météo complète
de michel tour est très bonne soirée 6 1
6 3
m